[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
happy almost July 4th everyone I'm Tom
shallou in for Greg who's celebrating
the holiday by reading his autobiography
to orphans
since it's almost Independence Day we
should give this some thought we keep
asking our politicians to get things
done who will make my gas cheaper who'll
pay my student loans well I was recently
looking at that famous JFK inauguration
speech you remember the one
ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country a great
line right
and
really a gutsy line for a politician I
mean think about it it's his first day
in office and he says my fellow
Americans don't look at me
you want something done do it yourself
that is refreshing isn't it and that's
what I want to hear more of from now on
when I'm looking at candidates I only
have one thing on my wish list give me
this one thing and all the other things
fall into place Give Me Freedom
it's sad that we have to say that isn't
it it's supposed to be a given remember
the Constitution the first amendment is
all about Freedom there's a reason the
founding fathers put it first hey thanks
old white guys
[Music]
[Applause]
but the bureaucrats in charge say
freedom is great but it'll have to wait
we're in a climate crisis we're in a
health emergency we have a banking
crisis we'll fix it for you your freedom
will be back soon thank you for your
patience We're All in This Together
no thank you and if there's one thing
I'm sure of it's that we are not all in
this together so let's try Freedom shall
we freedom to run my business and if you
try to take it away I'm gonna throw
pizza at you
[Applause]
yeah and medical Freedom this has to be
absolute no required Medical Treatments
none and never again will we engage in
These Foolish protocols by people who
look like they think Donuts are a
vegetable
no testing I'm not going to stick a swab
up my nose for you
and no temperature checks how did anyone
ever think this was acceptable in order
to come into my establishment you're
going to have to let me point this gun
at your head and pull the trigger okay
sounds great
no contact tracing I'm not going to tell
you who I've been meeting with where
I've been that never should have
happened and freedom of thought which is
the big one the one they fear more than
anything else no matter what marigarland
believes you're allowed to think
whatever you want to think whether it's
true or not that second part very
important people like to say things like
you're allowed to believe what you want
but you're not allowed to spread
misinformation
yes yes you are
that's the whole idea of freedom of
speech you're allowed to speculate
you're allowed to opinionate you're
allowed to blow V8 like we're about to
do on tonight's show
this is America not Canada
so say it with me at home would you you
are allowed to say things that may not
be true things like
I'm a journalist
or bidenomics is working for the
American people
or
I am tall
you can say it
so let's hear it for freedom and
remember the words of JFK ask not
because when it came to Freedom those
guys at Lexington and Concord didn't ask
they went out and got it
yeah otherwise go ahead go ahead
otherwise with the way this country's
going we're going to be seeing
commercials like this
because of the current state of the
nation bank failures
skyrocketing crime
civil unrest
inflation and a tenth damn fast and
furious movie the United States
government has decided to throw in the
towel
that's right if the United States of
America going out of business sale
you'll enjoy nation-sized savings on
everything from bricks and tunnels to
notepads and fighter planes
that's right we've got nuclear-powered
aircraft carriers prized to move boys to
move not to mention rock bottom prices
on courthouses and Office Buildings plus
you'll enjoy 3.9 financing on lightly
used national monuments lightly used
national monuments and if you act now
we'll throw in a complimentary predator
drone with every purchase
a business sale call your Congressman
for details but hurry when America's
done so are the savings
[Music]
let's welcome tonight's guests she
taught Katy Perry what a real firework
is former State Department spokeswoman
and founder of Polaris National Security
Morgan Ortegas
[Applause]
this Jesus is looking for Apostles but
you have to apply on Twitter
social scientist and YouTube host hotep
Jesus
he's got nerves of Steel and feet to
match retired Marine Corps bomb
technicians
and police use his act to disperse
unruly crowds comedian Joe Mackey
I'm sorry Joe that joke was left over
from uh gutfeld's uh introductions
I'm just crowd hitting boo yeah
so true look this is uh this whole
monologue Morgan was something I wanted
to do based on the idea I hear
conservatives say this all the time if
someone will say you uh you know you
have a right to your to free speech but
you can't employ misinformation and I
say no no if you're really conservative
this is the this is called the right to
be wrong do you know what I mean you
have the right to be a dumbass in
America absolutely yeah I mean that is
enshrined in our Constitution and so
it's true the Democrats build a whole
party around it
do what you got to do by the way I just
have to I have to take it aside I know
that the camera keeps showing me but
everyone thinks that Joey loves America
the most because he gave up his legs for
this country I just have to say I love
America the most tonight I have on my
American flag pants
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a close race
for my America pants for fashion only
you have tremendously better legs than
out ever
sorry I had to digress and talk about my
pants well you know how do you feel
about the state of freedom in America a
lot of what I said had to do with the
medical stuff because I do think that
was the worst infringement on America
American freedoms that we've seen that
we've ever seen well luckily we have
this show we have Greg we have you we
have Joe we have everybody that can come
here and give the middle finger to all
of the self-proclaimed sensors so I'm
okay with that
that's true uh hotep what do you think
of the state of freedom I mean we're
coming we're here I don't want to be a
downer because we're here we're coming
to the Fourth of July but where is
freedom in America today we have lots of
Freedom uh especially this unit election
we have a lot of great options we have a
Juiced up anti-vaxxer uh we have a
governor with the Charisma of Jeb Bush
we have a dementia patient with a
crackhead son who don't take care of his
babies
[Laughter]
[Applause]
who's
Johnny Joey Jones
we are uh are we in a a freedom crisis
do we have to remember what you know
what our Founders they put in these
documents and now we have bureaucrats
who say well no uh you know we we
believe we had the president say uh give
me a break with your freedom I heard a
Schwarzenegger say that though damn your
freedoms
he needs to get back in the chopper man
get the hell on out of here yeah Hey
listen what we have in this country the
plague that we're we're really
discouraged that we're really dealing
with is institutionalized insecurity
we're no longer told we can go make it
for ourselves we don't even believe we
can have children and take care of them
anymore so the things we don't do now
like partaking our freedoms or because
we've been indoctrinated or at least our
kids have and not believing in ourselves
enough to take any kind of risk to go
get it done you can't go start a
business so you need to work for the
government you don't need to have five
kids because you can't raise them or you
don't even have what it takes to raise
the kids you have and so that's the
problem we have institutionalized
insecurity within us and what happens
with insecure people they lash out in
irrational ways they create safe spaces
because they're afraid to hear something
they don't like they uh they call
everything an ISS it's racist misogynist
whatever it is not to say those things
aren't real they're just not real every
time you say them and so this type of
insecurity that exists among young
people but now even Millennials and so
many generations of Americans has been
learned it's not within us the spirit of
America lives within us and that's a
spirit of hey you know what you tell me
I can't do it dare me because I'm going
to go do it and show you that's what
Independence there you go
Jeremy
Joe Mack you should Americans appreciate
Freedom more and what can we do to to
get it through to them of course we
should appreciate Freedom more and I
just want to say I almost wore my flight
pants today and have we both worn flag
pants we gonna look silly
um
and wow that was inspirational I I wish
you could have helped me out I didn't
father all those kids
but I'll I'll say what the problem is
here Tom the government will mess up and
then give itself more power for instance
on 911 a couple of the pilots of the
hijacked planes the hijackers uh
violated the rules of their visas then
they committed this atrocity and uh
instead of the government saying well we
should enforce the laws that we already
have the power to enforce uh they have
to see my penis when I go on an airplane
and if I say you can't see my penis
they're like well then we get to touch
your penis and they're like well that's
that was that was worse than the first
one it's like too bad options it's like
voting you know and that doesn't really
actually happen to everybody else I
don't what I don't know who you're going
through security don't let them Touch
Your Penis anymore are you offering are
you like no the security can can see
your the machine can see that oh okay
let's let's talk about this more offline
but the thing that the thing that I'm
trying to say is Tom we have to stay
vigilant against government overage for
instance the fisa court is up for
Renewal and basically with what the fisa
court is it's a it's a fake court
because you can't have a real Court
that's secret and has one side but uh
instead of instead of you know saying
with indignation that this needs to end
a lot of people just aren't paying
attention we're talking about we're
spending the whole time talking about
flag pants
it is it is controversial but and I do
appreciate that and that's why I said we
need we we need that revolutionary
Spirit again instead of begging for our
freedoms we're just gonna have to go out
and take them right